einstiegs runde hier heute abend bei uns
ist der bundeswirtschaftsminister herr
altmaier eine bazooka ist nicht sehr
präzise und sie reißt ziemlich große
löcher sind sie sicher dass das die
richtigen trifft und dass sie nicht das
ganze pulver verschießen die bazooka hat
olaf scholz und die bundesregierung vor
zwei monaten auf dem tisch gelegt als es
darum ging ganz schnell zu verhindern
dass ganz viele menschen arbeitslos
werden dass ganz viele unternehmen
zerbrechen jetzt leisten wählte die sehr
zielgenau ist für familien mit kindern
für unternehmen die investieren für die
entwicklung von neuen hoch innovativen
technologien das ist ein unterschied und
deshalb wird dieses paket auch über den
tag hinaus
es wird über den tag hinausreichen und
jetzt die frage muss gegebenenfalls
nochmals nachgelegt werden bei uns ist
annalena baerbock eine der zwei
vorsitzenden der grünen frau baerbock
weniger mehrwertsteuer kein geld für
verbrenner autos investitionen in grüne
technologien und überhaupt finden sie in
der suppe das geht nicht um um haare in
der suppe zu finden sondern es geht ja
darum ob dieses paket uns gemeinsam in
die zukunft führt und vor allem der
wirtschaftskrise verhindert
und aus meiner sicht steckt da einiges
gutes drin um eben zu verhindern dass
wir in der wirtschaftskrise rutschen
aber der große wurf dass es wirklich ein
investitionspaket für die zukunft ist
dass es aus meiner sicht leider nicht in
allen teilen das schlimmste wurde
verhindert sie haben das mit der
abwrackprämie für verbrenner
angesprochen aber die weichen richtung
nachhaltige klimafreundliche wirtschaft
wurden eben nicht umfassend gestellt und
es hat eine soziale schieflage weil
manche eben gar nicht erfasst werden
insbesondere die ärmsten der
gesellschaft also regelsätze hat hier
kommt überhaupt nicht vor solo
selbstständige diejenigen die wirklich
um ihre existenz irgendwie ihre
absicherung bringen die kommen leider
nicht vor und das ist aus meiner sicht
eben das defizit an dieser geht
darüber werden wir reden lars feld ist
uns aus freiburg zugeschaltet der chef
der wirtschaftsweisen
er fällt es könne kein freibier für alle
geben hatten sie gewarnt
kommt die bundesregierung
trotzdem im leben mit einer großen pole
aus hat sie trotzdem schlug über den
durst genommen na das wort vom freibier
für alle war ja auf die lange liste der
wünsche aus der wirtschaft aus
unterschiedlichen interessengruppen
herausgelöst und da muss ich schon sagen
meine positive überraschung gestern
abend als ich das las bestand auch
gerade darin dass sehr viel dieser
wünsche eben nicht einfach bedient
worden sind dass man versucht hat mit
allgemeinen maßnahmen die auch in der
lage sind richtige konjunktur
konjunkturelle impulse zu setzen
voran geht da gibt es ganz viele
verlustverrechnung beispielsweise wir
können auch über die
mehrwertsteuersenkung diskutieren
es gibt da auf der ausgabenseite eine
ganze reihe von maßnahmen ich war vor
allem auch froh dass manches nicht drin
ist also beispielsweise die auto prämie
für verbrenner aber auch eine regelung
für die kommunalen altschulden ist nicht
darin enthalten sondern eher etwas
zielgenau ist mit der zusätzlichen
übernahme weiterer teile der kosten der
unterkunft durch den bund also alles in
allem sehr viel licht sehr viel licht
werden die wahrscheinlich werden die
unternehmen das interessiert natürlich
nun viele unserer zuschauer werden die
die mehrwertsteuersenkung an den
verbraucher weitergeben oder werden sie
die einfach passieren dass befürchten
nämlich die menschen die uns zu schauen
ich würde davon ausgehen dass ein
erheblicher teil dieser
mehrwertsteuersenkung von den
unternehmen ein gestrichen wird
wir haben wenige empirische evidenz dazu
es gibt für die für das vereinigte
königreich eine analyse zur letzten
finanzkrise
da wurden 50 bis 75 prozent dieser
mehrwertsteuersenkung in gesunken in
niedrigeren preisen weitergegeben
jetzt für dieses halbe jahr sind
allerdings auch die administrativen
kosten in deutschland sehr sehr hoch um
die das ganze preis schema umzustellen
und wir haben selbst ja auch mit der
so genannten mövenpick steuer der dem
ermäßigten umsatzsteuersatz für
beherbergungsleistungen die erfahrung
gemacht dass diese steuersenkung so gut
wie gar nichts an die konsumenten
weitergegeben wurde
man muss aber sagen es ist dann
gleichwohl ein konjunkturimpuls der
allerdings eher bei den unternehmen als
bei den konsumenten ankommen wird da ist
schon eine erste kritik seiner user ist
bei uns sie sind unternehmerinnen in der
betonindustrie und sie sind
bundesvorsitzende der jungen
unternehmerinnen korrekter weise
jetzt wird es natürlich auch
mitnahmeeffekte geben es gibt andere
kritikpunkte aber es kam offensichtlich
auch auf den zeitpunkt an kann etwas
richtig sein weil es sofort hilft ohne
so zielgenau zu sein
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen an der
stelle muss man die politik mal loben es
wurde am anfang sehr schnell hilfen auf
die straße gebracht die vielen
unternehmen geholfen haben jetzt das
konjunkturpaket hat licht und schatten
das bedeutet es ist natürlich ein
sammelsurium an maßnahmen insgesamt 57
punkte von kinder boni bis hin zur
kaufprämie da ist natürlich der punkt
wir müssen schauen dass sie mit dem
konjunkturpaket wirklich die wirtschaft
ankurbeln und um die wirtschaft
breitflächig anzukurbeln brauchen wir
eine entlastung der unternehmen der
arbeitgeber das heißt eigentlich steuern
runter eine entlastung der arbeitnehmer
auch da dass arbeitnehmer mehr netto vom
brutto übrig haben
das wäre mit ein instrument wie man die
wirtschaft ankurbeln kann da hören wir
in einer krise in einer neuen krise alte
forderungen bei uns ist manuela konnte
bundesjugendsekretär in beim dgb frau
konnte interessanterweise findet sich
eben auch in diesem paket im nicht die
abschaffung des solis für alle die
reichen werden ihnen weiter zahlen
müssen es wird auch viel für
geringverdiener getan sagen sie als
gewerkschafterin
da hätte ich diese regierung nicht so
gut drauf und ich muss sagen ich hab es
mir gewünscht dass sein
ein großer das ist ein großer wurf wird
und viele punkte berücksichtigt werden
wir sagen dieses paket kann
beschäftigung sichern ohne zeit
handlungsfähigkeit auch in schwierigen
situationen
ich möchte gerne auch auf drei punkte
gezielt eingehen und zwar ist eben schon
gesagt worden es geht um die
mehrwertsteuer dass die auch durch
verringerte preise bei den verbrauchern
ankommt das elementar der zweite punkt
der für uns als gewerkschaftsjugend auch
wichtig ist wir sagen der korona krise
darf keine ausbildungskrise folgen und
deswegen ist es gut dass die regierung
jetzt ein paket geschnürt hat einen
rettungsschirm gespannt hat für die
auszubildenden die beschriebenen
maßnahmen altmaier kommen gar nicht mehr
raus aus dem die beschriebenen maßnahmen
wie beispielsweise der übernahme bonus
wenn man auszubildende aus insolventen
betrieben übernimmt und auch die
förderung von ausbildung statt
kurzarbeit sind elementar wir sagen auch
ist es wichtig dritte sogar noch zur
ausbildung dazu weil es schon wichtig
ist ja auch ein ausbildungsbonus genannt
wurden beschrieben worden wofür uns sehr
wichtig ist dass in der umsetzung das
gekoppelt wird auch an
qualitätsstandards der ausbildung und an
die tatsächliche notlage der unternehmen
weil wir brauchen keine ausbeutung bonus
deswegen ist es wichtig genau
hinzuschauen und der dritte punkt last
but noch least werden uns wesentlich
mehr bums gewünscht was die studierenden
angeht weil die komplett beim
konjunkturpaket gehen die leer aus sie
bleiben weiter im regen stehen weil auch
die bisherigen maßnahmen reichen bei
weitem nicht aus so merken wir uns alles
fragen muss man sagen dass bei diesem
konjunkturpaket auch interessant ist wer
nicht als gewinner vom parkett ging lars
feld hat das schon angesprochen
beispielsweise die automobilindustrie
als große lobby ist mit den verbrennern
sagen sie das ist gut
grundsätzlich sind wir von seiten der
junge unternehmer gegen kaufprämien weil
sie sehr branchenspezifisch sind jetzt
die kaufprämie für e autos ist auch
nicht der richtige weg weil wir sollten
technologie offen bleiben wir sollten
lösungen schaffen um die konjunktur im
generell anzukurbeln das heißt
branchenübergreifend das sind genau
diese punkte wir brauchen bessere
rahmenbedingungen in deutschland um
einen wirtschaftsstandort zu schaffen
der attraktiv ist dass sich unternehmen
hier ansiedeln dass wir gute umgebungen
haben wie einen schlanken effektiven und
digitalen staat wir brauchen ein
digitales wirtschaftswunder also es gibt
viele punkte die alle branchen mit
einbeziehen sollten
und nur die automobilindustrie in den
fokus zu nehmen das ist nicht der
richtige weg
nun war ja interessant winfried
kretschmann ministerpräsident in
baden-württemberg hatte auch staatsgeld
gefordert für die verbrenner frau
berbalk ist es nicht ein bisschen
peinlich wenn das schwarz und rot grüner
sind als ein grüner na da haben sich der
drei ministerpräsidenten von drei
ausländern zu höherer materialpreise
genau und wir als grüne partei haben
sehr deutlich gesagt dass wir das falsch
finden weil wir gezielt in die zukunft
investieren müssen und dann kann man
nicht die alten verbrenner die
automobilbranche in den letzten jahren
schon nicht losgeworden ist jetzt noch
mal unterstützen fördern
man muss jetzt bei diesem paket aber
auch sehr genau hinschauen also wenn man
sich in die details jetzt nicht an
stefan altmeyer nur auch noch mal nach
der kaufprämie fragen sie haben auch für
den verbrenner plädiert haben auch
gesagt kaufprämie für autos ist richtig
wie haben sich die autobosse bei ihnen
schon wütend gemeldet und dann die
autobosse haben sich nicht gemeldet
sondern das haben sich ganz viele
gewerkschaften gemeldet die gesagt haben
vielen dank dass sie sich für die
interessen unserer beschäftigten
eingesetzt haben wir haben in der
automobilindustrie 800.000 beschäftigte
darunter daran hängen mehrere millionen
im bereich der zulieferindustrie und
alle diese menschen haben im augenblick
sorge um ihre arbeitsplätze
wir fordern elektroautos ist ich glaube
inzwischen so viel wie sich niemand
vorstellen konnte
und das ist richtig aber selbst findet
es alle bürger elektroautos bestellen
würden sie könnten in deutschland nicht
gebaut werden dass die kapazitäten nicht
gibt auch nicht im nächsten übernächsten
jahr das ist ein prozess den wir
vorantreiben
und deshalb war die frage wenn wir den
maschinenbau helfen wollen den
zulieferern im automobilbau der
industrie dann war das eine der
möglichkeiten
wir haben das anders gelöst durch die
mehrwertsteuersenkung auch das war eine
möglichkeit
und für mich ist eines wichtig dass wir
dieses programm gemeinsam
parteiübergreifend zustande gebracht
haben
mit viel unterstützung aus allen seiten
dass es die voraussetzung dafür dass es
wirkt ich habe heute sehr viele positive
stimmen erlebt auf meinem handy per sms
und twitter
das zeigt die menschen wollen dass es
wieder aufwärts geht und wir müssen
ihnen dabei helfen die müssen hält
frau konnte jetzt ist ja interessant
dass auch die union cdu csu
offensichtlich ganz viel geld in die
nachfrage gibt und ausgerechnet die
linke beschwert sich darüber dass dessen
gießkannenprinzip sei und das ist ein
strohfeuer sei wird die politische
landschaft wird die politische geografie
decken sie gerade auf den kopf gestellt
nein das würde ich nicht sagen aber man
muss natürlich sehen dass man so viele
maßnahmen eingerichtet oder beschlossen
werden dass man auch schaut bekommen
diese maßnahmen an
ich habe es ja eben schon mal gesagt mit
der mehrwertsteuer zum beispiel aber
auch der ausbildungsbonus an welche
qualitätsstandard ist das ist das
gekoppelt geben wir gezielt geld leihen
oder stecken mit den playern wie dem
amazon chef einfach noch ein bisschen
mehr geld in die tasche
also wir müssen auch gucken wo wir das
geld ausgeben konjunkturpakete insgesamt
auch das wollen wir noch mal sagen haben
jetzt nicht nur fans unter den ökonomen
die bundesregierung will großzügig geld
verteilen gar nicht notwendig sagt der
wirtschaftsforscher oliver holtemöller
aus meiner sicht brauchen wir derzeit
kein konjunkturpaket so richtig es ist
jetzt in der krise nicht zu sparen
so können wir dennoch nicht pauschal
alle menschen besser stellen
stattdessen sollten wir uns auf
diejenigen konzentrieren die
einkommenseinbußen haben einen klar
erkennbaren focus vermisst auch der
wirtschaftsweise volker wieland
es wurde eine chance vergeben das
konjunkturpaket vom umfang her auf
einige zentrale maßnahmen zu
konzentrieren
kostet viel bringt wenig diese sorge
hatte auch ein anderer
konjunkturprogramme verpufften wie
strohfeuer und verbrennen am ende nur
geld sagte noch im herbst 2009 10 unser
gast peter altmaier
herr altmaier was interessiert mich mein
satz von gestern
die schwarze null die schuldenbremse die
schwäbische hausfrau das sind jetzt
alles opfer des corona wir uns nein die
sätze interessieren mich nach wie vor
brennen weil ich glaube dass wir jetzt
nur den menschen helfen können weil wir
in den letzten zehn jahren erfolgreiche
wirtschaftspolitik gemacht haben und
weil wir mit dem geld der bürger
verantwortlich umgegangen sind so
deshalb möchte ich auch dass für die
künftigen generationen star ist wie
erklären sobald das möglich ist zu
ausgeglichenen haushalten zurück und wir
setzen das geld vernünftig 1
ich habe mich in der tat gegen rain
konsumtive konjunkturprogramme immer
gewehrt rechte auffassung bin dass sie
vor prüfen aber ich habe aus ganzem
herzen die prämie für familien und
kinder unterstützt die einmalzahlung von
300 euro pro kind weil wir gerade auch
familien mit kindern in dieser krise
sehr viel zumuten mussten die haben ganz
große herausforderungen gehabt und ich
glaube dass man dankeschön sagt und
sicherstellt dass alle die geholfen
haben die infektionen einzugrenzen dann
auch merken das ist im aufschwung für
alle er kommt irgendwo bei jedem an über
mehrwertsteuer über wir retten auch
viele unternehmen im übrigen und dass
sie nicht pleite gehen weil sie keinen
umsatz haben durch das neue
überbrückungs programm das ist glaube
ich etwas was helfen kann dass wir diese
gemeinsamkeit die sich gezeigt hat seit
einigen wochen und monaten dass die auch
direkt über den sommer hinweg wo wir sie
und jetzt sagt interessanterweise frau
annegret kramp-karrenbauer das die
handschrift der cdu klar erkennbar sei
in diesem paket schulden die sich durch
wachstum selbst finanzieren ist es nicht
das glatte gegenteil dessen was die
union immer gesagt hat ja also wir
brauchen eine schnelle rückkehr zur
schuldenbremse ganz klar und das sollte
auch bis nächstes jahr feststehen wann
das passiert weil wir haben wir helfen
hier enorme corona schuldenberge an die
vor allem die junge generation bezahlen
also auch die steuerzahler das heißt
mich schockiert eigentlich dass die
frage nicht gestellt wird wer soll das
ganze bezahlen es wurde hier die
schatztruhe aufgemacht wünsch dir was
man will die konjunktur ankurbeln was
wichtig ist aber wenn wir gerade auf das
thema kinderbonus zu sprechen kommen
eine einmalzahlung von 300 euro ist
nämlich eher eine beruhigungspille für
die eltern und kinder lieber sollten wir
schauen dass langfristig die eltern die
familien mehr in der kasse haben das
heißt mehr netto vom brutto übrig haben
dass wir da mit den steuern und abgaben
runtergehen familien haben sicherlich
lieber gern 50 oder 100 euro mehr pro
monat als nur einmalig 300 euro weil
diese milliarden hätte man auch
investieren können in neue digitale
bildungs formate in die anmietung von
räumen damit die klassen auch
unterrichtet werden können mit genug
abstand also da gebe es noch andere
möglichkeiten um familien zu
unterstützen zu dieser digitalisierung
wenn da auch noch kommen die schuldenuhr
beim bund der steuerzahler das ist auch
schon mal klar die sport gerade durch
werden sie ganz kurz noch mal schauen
wollen die kosten der korona krise
zusammengesetzt aus mehrausgaben und
mindereinnahmen beliefen sich bei bund
ländern und kommunen bereits auf 287,5
milliarden euro rechnet man nun das
konjunkturpaket hinzu ergibt sich eine
gigantische summe 400 17,5 milliarden
euro der box schulden belasten die
zukünftigen generationen gilt dieser
lehrsatz nicht mehr
doch der gilt aber genauso geht das wenn
wir jetzt nicht in infrastruktur
investieren wenn wir jetzt nicht
langfristige investitionen sichern in
bildung im digitalisierung auch in der
transformation der industrie
dann ist der klimaschäden berg dann ist
der bildung schuldenberg noch viel
größer und wir haben ja derzeit den
vorteil dass wir ein negativzins haben
das heißt er ich hab da auch ein
bisschen zu sagen und zwei jahren müssen
wir jetzt zurück zuvor zum sparprogramm
das würde alles kaputt machen was man
jetzt ja versucht anzureizen weil so ein
konjunkturprogramm das wirkt ja nur wenn
die investition langfristig gestreut
werden und würde da gerne noch mal
auf dem automobil punkt auch
zurückkommen weil sie sich ja da hat jan
altmann übergeben hatten
sie haben ja im letzten satz dann gesagt
na ja wir haben die kaufprämie für
verbrenner nicht da führen wir die
mehrwertsteuersenkung und das ist
natürlich fatal wenn wir jetzt mit
milliarden weichen stellen da wäre wenn
ich in drei jahren nochmal milliarden
programme auflegen können für den
industriestandort deutschland dann
müssen die schon in die richtige
richtung gehen und jetzt bringt man
zweigleisig
man sagt man unterstütze halt meist
haben sie ja gerade sehr offen gesagt
durch die mehrwertsteuersenkung dann
auch noch teure große benziner
das heißt die wirkliche weichen das in
zukunft sauberer autos in deutschland
produziert werden
die macht man damit dann wieder kaputt
das heißt wir wollten eigentlich eine
produktions rückverlagerung von
produktionsstätten wenn bmw jetzt
elektroauto in china produziert ziel
muss es doch sein um arbeitsplätze zu
sichern
in zukunft das in europa in deutschland
zu produzieren und das kann man nicht
wenn man weiter zweigleisig fährt auf
der einen seite das haben sie drin das
habe ich heute auch gelobt wirklich im
klimabereich investitionen auf den weg
bringt aber im fossilen bereich danach
wie vor eben die subvention nicht runter
fährt oder sogar durch die hintertür im
zweifel dann auch durch hybride die
nicht elektrisch gefahren werden dass
alles wieder zunichte macht und da muss
man sich entscheiden weil ansonsten
haben wir keine schulden plus milliarden
die jetzt investiert werden die
irgendwann auch zurückgezahlt werde als
meine also die frage hätte man diese
milliarden beispielsweise für die
autoindustrie nicht verbinden sollen mit
forderungen mit klaren bedingungen wir
haben keine milliarden an die
autoindustrie gegeben dass finden sie
nirgendwo im programm
wenn die mehrwertsteuersenkung gesagt ja
wir senken mehrwertsteuer für den
verbraucher der verbraucher zahlt die
mehrwertsteuer und warum vier steilen
entscheiden schreiben dem verbraucher
nicht vor wo er sein geld einsetzt wenn
sich jemand einen cd-player kauft und
ein anderer möchte sich gerne eine
schöne truppe kaufen und ein dritter
neue kleider neues outfit ist das seine
entscheidung einer freien gesellschaft
im übrigen halte ich ihrem vergleich an
einem punkt bei vieler übereinstimmung
im übrigen nicht für richtig
es können eben nicht alle verbrenner auf
einen schwach ausgetauscht werden durch
elektroautos das weiß auch ihre partei
das so und dann ist es mir zehnmal
lieber dass jemand der im auto dass
viele
7 89 jahre alt ist und sehr viel mehr
co2 produziert dieses auto austausch
gegen eines was die modernsten
abgasvorschriften erfüllt und dazu
beiträgt dass wir weniger stickoxide
weniger co2 in die umwelt pusten
ich glaube das muss man aussprechen
ehrlichkeit gehört dazu und es gibt ja
auch in ihrer partei nicht nur den
winfried kretschmann es gibt viele die
hinter vorgehaltener hand sagen ja so
unrecht hat er wird er halt mal mit dem
punkt nicht aber das kann man öffentlich
nicht diskutieren
sie haben sich jetzt ja auch nicht
durchgesetzt mit dem verbrenner punkt
zum glück muss ich sagen
in diesem konjunkturpaket und die frage
ist doch wollen wir das in zukunft große
deutsche automobilkonzerne mit
wahnsinnig vielen zulieferern hat
800.000 beschäftigen ob die auch noch in
fünf in zehn jahren in deutschland
produzieren und wenn wir jetzt nicht
alle vehemenz darauf setzen dass die
batterien hier gefördert werden dass die
großen frosch und conti das die ihre
batterien hier baue ich weiß sie haben
was für batterien fertigung mit in dem
programm drin aber sie werden haben sie
werden werden dass doch aber nicht
sozusagen in der breite durchsetzen
können wenn sie zeitgleich sagen wir
halten an der alten technologie völlig
alba berlin in china und asien
produziert dann aber als
wirtschaftsminister dafür gesorgt dass
wir milliarden in die hand genommen
haben und wir haben inzwischen 60
unternehmen die in diese technologie
investieren wir werden in zwei jahren in
rheinland pfalz in kaiserslautern mit
2000 beschäftigten die ersten batterien
wieder in deutschland produzieren und
wir haben die mittel gerade noch einmal
deutlich aufgestockt in der
größenordnung von etwa 1 bis anderthalb
milliarden wird tun das alles weil wir
wollen dass unsere gesellschaft
nachhaltig wird und wir investieren auch
digitalisierung weil wir überzeugt sind
wir werden in deutschland auf dauer nur
produzieren können wenn es nach den
modernsten digitalen technik in der
automatisation geht ansonsten kommen wir
ins hintertreffen gegenüber ländern wie
china und ich bin ganz bei ihnen
dass wir auch erreichen müssen dass
autos weiterhin in deutschland gebaut
werden das schaffen wir aber nur wenn
die rahmenbedingungen stimmen wenn sich
investitionen rechnen wenn man am ende
auch einen return und investment hat wie
das auf neudeutsch und manager der
station muss wenn es genug schlagen und
wir haben wir übrigens
die bauen sie auch die stehen auch im
programm lars feld in freiburg wird
nochmal gefragt nun steht diese diese
konjunkturpaket idee und das was da auf
dem tisch liegt seit gestern natürlich
unter einer besonderen überschrift
nämlich eigentlich den menschen
optimismus wiederzugeben
sie haben gesagt den menschen fehlt
momentan weniger das geld als der
optimismus glauben sie dass das mit
diesem paket einzulösen ist oder wieder
zurückkommt naja man muss ja sagen dass
der optimismus der den menschen fehlt
vor allen dingen auch deswegen nicht in
dem maße vorhanden dass man den bräuchte
weil sich die leute sorgen machen wegen
des virus
die konsumzurückhaltung die wir
beobachten beobachten hat ja sehr viel
damit zu tun dass die leute nicht gerne
die geschäfte gehen wenn sie angst haben
müssen sich anzustecken
und genau diese verunsicherung die
können wir nicht einfach mit
konjunkturpaketen lösen die kriegen wir
damit nicht weg das wird eigentlich nur
gehen wenn wir einerseits sehen dass wir
jetzt über den sommer mit eben dieser
welle rauskommen und weniger sorge haben
müssen in eine zweite infektionswelle
hineinzukommen
und auch müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
wir falls eine zweite infektionswelle
kommt besser darauf vorbereitet sind als
auf diese damit wird nicht die
wirtschaft wieder so runterfahren müssen
wie wir es in den monaten märz april mai
getan haben ich glaube da sind
wesentliche voraussetzungen dann kommt
der optimismus auch schon einmal von
alleine die leute werden dann gerne
wieder rausgehen viel stärker wieder die
sonstigen tätigkeiten aufnehmen
im moment ist ja gar nicht möglich mit
den mitteln die über das paket an die
konsumenten ausgeschüttet werden so
leichten den konsum umzusetzen sie
können nicht so leicht reisen
sie können nicht ohne weiteres in dem
maße in die gastronomie gehen wie vorher
weil sie haben nicht die möglichkeit den
konzertveranstaltungen und ähnliches zu
gehen also es gibt weiterhin große
restriktionen und das verunsichert die
menschen natürlich schon erheblich die
politik tut was möglich ist nur diesem
paket aber sie wird diese form der
verunsicherung nicht
lösen können